today on the matt walsh show roe is no
more and one of the greatest moments in
american history the supreme court
decision which codified the right to
murder babies has been finally and
officially overturned i'll have a lot to
say about that today as you can imagine
also the left continues to panic over
the other great supreme court decision
decided yesterday this one affirming our
right to carry firearms many very bad
arguments have been made against that
decision we'll review some of them today
meanwhile eric adams in new york says
that he will ignore the supreme court's
decision and work to undo it is this an
insurrection we're dealing with plus joe
biden accidentally shows off a note from
his staff that shows just how bad his
dementia has gotten and camila harris
humiliates herself while trying to play
basketball all of that and much more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
well today is uh just a wonderful day
first of all and it's so good that i
even i dressed i'm not dressed like a
slob for the first time on the air
that's how that's how important today is
um it's been nearly 50 years since roe v
wade was decided for half a century
we've lived under its tyranny those of
us who were lucky enough to live at all
that is actually uh you know because 60
million of us did not live over 60
million human children have been wiped
off the face of the earth during that
time executed one by one systematically
for profit all because nine guys and
robes pulled out their decoder rings
from their cracker jack boxes and found
the right to abortion written in
invisible ink somewhere in the document
and that was enough justification to
legalize the destruction of innocent
human life all across the country for
almost half a century
it's impossible to know what our society
deprived itself of what it sacrificed
aside from its soul
could one of the babies we killed have
come up with a cure for cancer could
there have been great leaders and
artists and thinkers and humanitarians
somewhere in that pile of bodies
almost certainly there were
how many inventors and pioneers were
thrown into the mass grave before they
even had a chance to speak to plead for
themselves to tell their side of the
story
we'll never know for sure because roe
robbed us of that just as it robbed 60
million children of their lives and of
their potential
until today
as expected for the last month and
prayed for and fought for and worked
towards for the last five decades by
pro-lifers roe was officially overturned
by the supreme court decision today a
decision originally leaked a few weeks
ago in a desperate bid to intimidate at
least one of the justices into changing
their minds the gambit did not pay off
indeed it probably backfired as roberts
joined chief justice robert to join the
majority decision overturning roe
something he almost certainly was not
planning to do until the decision leaked
and so it stands it stands even stronger
arguably than it did in its leaked form
and the result is that roe is no more
praise god
this is truly i mean truly one of the
greatest days in american history future
generations will look back on this day
you are living in a day right now you
are experiencing a day
that will be in the history books that
future generations will look back on
and they will look back on it the way
that they that we now look back on the
abolition of slavery or the defeat of
the germans in world war ii the
liberation of the concentration camps
they will look back on it the exact same
way
because there's a lot of gray area in
life there's many occasions where the
good guys aren't very distinguishable
from the bad guys but this
this belongs to the other category of
events this is the category where the
line between good and evil could not be
more clear
one side
has fought to protect babies from
extermination
and they have fought this and fought for
this for the sake of those babies of
those children
you know we pro-lifers we stand to gain
nothing personally from the end of row
we don't profit
off of it in any way at all
there's nothing self-serving about it
we fight for those who cannot fight for
themselves and this is really hard for
the left to understand because they
never do this everything they fight for
it's always for themselves
always
if they cannot directly profit from it
in some kind of way they do not fight
for it and they do not care
which is why they could never understand
us they never understood us as
pro-lifers they're always looking for
what's really going on here what's going
on below the surface what's the
nefarious plan what's that they're
trying to control women's bodies they
have a secret conspiracy it's none of
that
we just don't think you should kill
babies
simple as that
we care about those babies
the other side they fight to destroy
innocent life
and they fight for it
for their own sake for their own
convenience for their own precious
lifestyle and comfort
they're the bad guys
history will see them
as the bad guys
we'll see them that way we'll look back
on them with scorn
and you should know that also if you're
on the left and today you're very upset
and you're screaming and crying about it
that all of history will look back at
you
and and with scorn and mockery and
derision
as well as should
because you lose you lose big today you
lose historically
and look they're going to explode in
demonic rage they're going to protest
and riot
they will destroy probably kill to
satiate their bloodlust but none of that
will change anything and all of it will
be worth it in the end let these
psychopaths burn every city to the
ground i will still thank god
that roe is no more
now i don't think they're actually going
to follow through on a lot of this stuff
i think a lot of it is just a big talk
i think i think that the pro-abortion
militants are hoping hoping and praying
to satan
that that we'll have you know the blm
riots of 2020 all over again that will
have months and months of chaos and
riding in the street that's what they're
hoping for that's what they're trying to
organize i don't think it's actually
going to happen
because i don't think
that there are enough people and maybe
i'll be proven wrong about this
i don't think there are enough people
who care that much about killing babies
to generate the kind of mass nationwide
chaos that the left is hoping for here
we'll see
now this does not end the scourge of
abortion we should note that
may come as a shock to many of the
pro-abortion demons convulsing in the
street and vomiting all over themselves
like linda blair and the exorcist but in
fact abortion will remain legal in many
u.s states including our most populous
states in fact nearly every pro-abortion
militant now promising a night of rage
as revenge
actually lives in a place where their
so-called right to abortion quote
unquote will remain intact
actually i expect that the remaining
abortion states will double and triple
down consoling themselves by making
abortion even more accessible even more
legal even more easy to obtain
i'm i'm putting my market down right
here i don't think this year will come
to a close before at least one state
officially legalizes infanticide
expanding abortion rights into the first
several months of a child's life outside
the womb
that's on the way
and yet even so this decision today will
nonetheless directly save millions of
lives
there is no question about that it is
not every day that something like this
happens that there's an event in history
that happens and we live through it and
because of that event millions of people
will live who otherwise would have died
i mean the the course of history has
been changed in ways that uh we cannot
possibly
tabulate or quantify we never will be
able to
it's important also to note something
else
that this decision
made by the court
is not just morally right though it is
of course morally right manifestly and
self-evidently so it's also the right
legal decision because even if somehow
you have no moral qualms with a
dismemberment of children
you must if you're honest and understand
the way the law is supposed to work
you must agree that roe was bad law bad
precedent a bad decision built on a
foundation so flimsy that to call it
merely flimsy probably does it a favor
i want to read a little bit from the
decision itself um today it says quote
without any grounding in the
constitutional text history or precedent
row imposed on the entire country a
detailed set of rules for pregnancy
divided into trimesters much like those
that one might expect to find in a
statute or regulation
roe's failure even to note the
overwhelming consensus of state laws in
effect in 1868 is striking
and what it said about the common law
was simply wrong
then after surveying history the opinion
spent many paragraphs conducting the
sort of
fact-finding that might be undertaken by
a legislative committee and did not
explain why the sources on which it
relies shed light on the meaning of the
constitution
as to precedent citing a broad array of
cases the court found support for a
constitutional right of personal privacy
but roe conflated the right to shield
information from disclosure and the
right to make and implement personal
decisions without governmental
interference
none of these decisions involved what is
distinctive about abortion its effect on
what rho termed potential life
when the court summarized the basis for
the scheme it imposed on the country it
asserted that its rules were consistent
with among other things the relative
weight of the respective interests
involved in the demands of the profound
problems of the present day
these are precisely the sort of
considerations that legislative bodies
often take into account when they draw
lines that accommodate competing
interests the scheme produced looked
like legislation and the court provided
the sort of explanation that might be
expected from a legislative body
okay now
the entire decision is uh very much
worth reading but that passage alone
summarizes i think
a central element of the majority's
decision
basically to translate the decision to
affirm a constitutional right to
abortion quote unquote
was not grounded in the text of the
constitution because it's not in the
text of the constitution
it wasn't even grounded in precedent or
historical tradition it had no grounding
at all aside from the claims and
preferences of the justices who decided
it
what they came up with then was not a
legal decision rigorously argued but a
kind of pseudo legislation that looks
and sounds and functions like something
that a legislative committee might come
up with
and that's reason enough to overturn it
no matter how you feel about abortion
and you can really see the contrast
between row itself that decision and the
decision abolishing it today
the latter the decision abolishing it is
thorough logical
deeply argued
while the former is what it was now we
say was shallow often absurd full of
subjective assertions and it danced
around and avoided the fundamental
question which of course is what we
always find on the left
they could never take any issue head-on
they can never talk about it directly
everything is covered in euphemism
everything is just a game of beating
around the bush
because here is the most fundamental
question
that all pro-abortion people everywhere
avoid it's the question that the rioters
in the street tonight while they're
looting and burning will have no answer
to and probably haven't even thought
about and that is this
what is a person
we know they can't tell us what a woman
is which won't stop them from claiming
that today represents a grave assault on
women's rights
but that confusion is not surprising
since they long before
gave up on the definition of the word
person
i mean before they gave up on the
definition of word woman the word woman
they'd given up on the definition of the
word person which means that we had
already become these kinds of sort of
vague hazy
ambiguous um
undefinable undefined
lumps of of matter you know that's
that's what a person is now it's like
nothing at all
and of course if that's the case then
any other label you put on the person
also doesn't really make any sense
because we don't know we don't know
anything about the underlying person
for 50 years they claimed that the
question is irrelevant they said well
nobody knows what a person is it's
impossible to say so let's just keep
killing these babies just in case
but any morally sane person realizes
that it should go the other way
if you can't tell me what a person is
then you can't say for certain that the
child in the womb is not one
which means even by your own logic you
should refrain from killing him
if you point a gun at somebody not
knowing if it's loaded or not and you
pull the trigger
you're still legally liable if it turns
out there was a bullet in the chamber
after all unless her name is alec
baldwin of course
the same goes for abortion
by the pro board's own telling
they exterminated 60 million human
children who might have been people for
all they know
that's not any better than exterminating
60 million human children who you know
are people
especially in this case
because in fact everyone knows that
babies are people even if they pretend
to be confused about it
everyone knows it
a person is a human being
the child in the womb cannot be anything
other than a member of the human species
which he which means he cannot be
anything other than a person
these are people
they have been killing people
millions of them and they know it
and they'll answer to god for what
they've done
but today we celebrate their defeat
there's a lot of work yet to be done you
know the battle is uh just beginning in
many ways
but it's i think it's very important to
celebrate the victories when they come
and this is a victory
i mean this is a major one
this is one of the greatest victories
for human rights in the history of the
world i think i would even say
perhaps
the greatest victory for human rights in
the history of the world
and it's one that i thought i would
never live to see
in summation
what a great way to end pride month
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know the other i mean the other i
say the other great thing about this
there's so many great things i'm just
elated by it um but
you know who do we have to thank
for what for for this today for the
results um
well we thank the the uh six members of
the supreme court
who decided correctly on this well
roberts was kind of you know he he he
tried to
thread a a needle
um from what i saw in um in his opinion
on this he tried to thread a needle
where he would still
you know
preserve roe
while at the same time you know just
this kind of compromise that makes no
sense but who do we have to think
um the members of the supreme court have
made this heroic decision it truly is
heroic i mean keep in mind
brett kavanaugh and i i don't like
everything brett kavanaugh has done in
all the decisions that he's made since
he's been since he uh
was uh confirmed and um sworn into the
supreme court
but this is this is an act of real
courage
because keep in mind brett kavanaugh
there was a guy there was a nut case at
his house with a gun
and like zip ties ready to kidnap and
murder him
and and he knows they're not going to
stop after this
so they have put their lives on the line
these are real heroes
and no matter what else happens
and i'm sure in the future that they'll
have there'll be plenty of other
decisions where i disagree with where
some of these people fall
clarence thomas probably not i don't
think i've ever disagreed with any
decision he's made but um some of the
other ones that'll but because of this
moment right here they are heroes
forever they they have they have secured
that for themselves for all time
so we have them to think um
we have donald trump to thank for uh for
uh nominating
these justices these three justices in
the first place
now that's the fact of the matter if
donald trump had not won in 2016 if if
uh
if hillary clinton had won then
um roe v wade would be affirmed
obviously
the second amendment would be gone it
would just be gone by now and so much
else so if anything not just not just
donald trump by the way also mitch
mcconnell the senate republicans
who for one thing held the line refused
to confirm mayor garland
and uh even though i don't like mitch
mcconnell and he did just sell us out on
the gun control issue
still he had them to think as well but
even before that most of all um the the
pro-lifers who have been in the trenches
on this thing
fighting for this for for decades i mean
have given their lives to this
and um i have i have had the pleasure of
knowing many pro-lifers like that
um
having been in the movement myself and i
can tell you there are people that have
just
for the last 50 years there are people
that were they were around when this
happened when this decision was made and
they said to themselves then i'm giving
my life to this fight this is this is my
life and they and they gave the life to
it and they primarily are the ones who
achieve this victory
but then also i think we also have to
give an honorable mention maybe even
better more than an honorable mention to
ruth bader ginsburg herself rbg
if it was not for rbj rbg's um
hubris her narcissistic decision
to not retire i mean clinging on to her
to the honorific clinging on to the
position and the power for as long as
she could until she passed away if she
hadn't done that you know if she had
been a little bit less narcissistic a
little bit had less hubris less
arrogance than she would have retired
and um and her replacement would have
been appointed by a democrat
but she didn't and so really we have in
in many ways she's one of the people who
we can thank for this
thank you
rbg
all right um now we move on to some of
the reaction from the left and there's
going to be a lot more over the weekend
and they're as i said they're promising
their night of rage and their rioting
and looting we'll see how much of that
they actually get
um we'll see how it goes
we'll start with nancy pelosi who uh
minutes after this decision came down
she was in front of the press and she is
very very upset about this and let's go
through and just watch
some of these clips go ahead
there's no point in saying good morning
because it certainly is not one
this morning the radical supreme court
is eviscerating americans rights and
endangering their health and safety
but the congress will continue to act
to overcome this extremism extremism and
protect the american people
today the republican-controlled supreme
court has achieved their dark
extreme goal of ripping away a woman's
right to
make their own dis reproductive health
decisions
because of donald trump mitch mcconnell
and the republican party their super
majority in the supreme court
american women today have less freedom
than their mothers
um well uh i mean where do you even
begin there she says that americans have
uh well girls have less freedoms than
their mothers well that's that's um you
know here's a freedom
that many americans have
which they did not have before this
morning and that is the freedom to be
born
to live in the first place
because your so-called reproductive
rights um you cannot
enjoy those
if you don't live in the first place and
here's the good news uh nancy pelosi
your reproductive freedom and your
reproductive rights are still intact you
still have those absolutely 100
and as i've said many times i am when it
comes to protecting reproductive rights
uh i i am right there with you i mean i
absolutely believe
that people should be free to reproduce
when and how they so
they choose okay nobody should be forced
to reproduce absolutely
the good thing is that um
we all agree on that
you know there's 330 million people in
america that's 300 million people 330
million people who agree
unanimous agreement supreme court agrees
nobody should be forced to reproduce
the issue as i'm constantly having to
remind the left is that when a baby is
aborted that's not a matter of
preventing reproduction because the
reproduction has already happened
okay the the baby has been produced
if the baby had not been produced then
there'd be no need for an abortion
okay once conception occurs that is
reproduction right there that is the
reproductive act that is reproduction
right there a
a distinct separate entity a distinct
separate being
with its with its own dna
with its own identity
has come into formation in that moment
and that's when reproduction happens
so the right to uh to reap your
reproductive rights that really comes
down to you deciding
um when and how you will and and with
whom you will engage
in the reproductive act
and as far as that goes we all we all
agree the reproductive
the reproductive act being not not
giving birth that's not the reproductive
act the reproductive act is the sexual
act
it's having sex that's the reproductive
act
um so nancy pelosi is very very
distraught and upset
this is a this is an an old woman
near the end of of her days you know
more than likely statistically that's
that's you know she's in her 80s
and here she is practically weeping over
the thought that more babies will be
allowed to live
and i can never get over that especially
with these old crusty
uh feminists
grandmother aged
like every grandmother i've ever known
they love babies
the idea of a grandmother my own
grandmother
weeping because more because babies will
not be killed it's just it's difficult
to make sense of that it's hard hard to
make at all compute
but this is what we're dealing with
from there pelosi starts talking about
the sinister and dastardly republican
agenda let's listen to that
in the congress
be aware of this the republicans
are plotting a nationwide abortion ban
they cannot be allowed to have a
majority in the congress
to do that
but that's their goal
and if you read
and again we're all studying all this
but if you read what is in the
very clear
one of the justices had his own
statement
it's about
contraception
in vitro fertilization
family planning
that is all what will spring
from their decision that they made today
did her glass eye just fall out of her
head at the end of that
i don't know what that was that was an
unexpected treat at the end there oh
that was her hearing that fell out okay
we'll just go a glass eye i think that
was her glasses she's just nancy pelosi
is physically falling apart it's like
the wicked witch right she's she's she's
melt someone should throw some water on
her and she would just melt right there
on stage
this old disgusting witch
um
and she's oh now they're gonna come over
after now what she's what she's
referring to is and i haven't read the
entire thing myself but a concurrent
decision
um or opinion by
clarence thomas where he talks about
some of the supreme court decisions
related to contraception and gay
marriage
and um how we have to take a look at the
basis of those decisions
and that's
and if if they are decided if they if
those were decided on a faulty basis
then yeah that's something the court
should rectify
um
but what we're talking about today is
very very fundamentally just the right
to life
and that's all that this decision
affects it doesn't go beyond that
next i want to play just one more clip
from her she says that she starts
talking about
something a point that she can't make
anymore but but these people keep making
anyway she says this is a this is an
insult and an attack on women go ahead
what this means to women is such an
insult
it's a slap in the face to women about
using their own judgment
to make their own decisions
about their reproductive freedom
and again it goes well i always have
said the termination of a pregnancy is
just their opening act it's just their
front game but because but beyond
behind it and for years i have seen in
this congress opposition to any family
planning domestic
or global
when we have had those discussions and
those debates and those votes on the
floor of the house
this is deadly serious
but we are not going to let this pass
a woman's right to choose
reproductive freedom is on the ballot in
november
okay at least she got her eyeball back
in her head um that's uh it's an insult
to women now obviously that that's a
point you can't make because you don't
know what a woman is in the first place
so how can you say that it's insulting a
group of people that you cannot define
but also um i can talk about that's the
advantage that i have and that people on
the pro-life side that's the advantage
that we have is that um we know what
women are so we can actually talk about
them and so what i can say is that it's
an insult to women to say that it's an
insult to women um
that when we when we simply protect the
lives of children and say that you can't
kill children like the idea
that
um it's crucial to a woman's
life it's crucial to her existence to
her success and happiness that she be
able to kill her children
i can't think of anything more insulting
and degrading to women than that idea
that is what insults women
and we're gonna hear a lot of this too
by the way we're gonna hear a lot about
the uh how women you know they're not
gonna be able to be successful anymore
they're it's gonna they're not gonna
have the happiness and fulfillment in
life anymore
because that's how the left views women
that's how many women on the left view
themselves
as sick as that is
that a woman's the way they see it that
a woman's happiness and fulfillment
uh and very existence
hinges on destruction it hinges on the
right to destroy and not just destroy
anybody but destroy her own children
now we as pro-lifers know that it's the
exact opposite is the case
that um
that
happiness
and fulfillment
can be found for a woman in that
relationship with her child this is a
this is a fulfilling
relationship
just as it is for a man with his child
um stacey abrams also had a little bit
of something to say here i haven't
watched this video yet but she's of
course chiming in right away and he's
quite upset about all this and for some
reason we care what stacey abrams has to
say so let's play a little bit of this
today the united states supreme court
the seat of justice charged with
protecting our liberties struck down
reproductive rights
in 1973 the supreme court's decision in
roe v wade safeguarded the right to
choose for millions of women across
georgia and around our nation
rather than uphold the wisdom of nearly
50 years women today lost the right to
make our own health care decisions and
the right to shape our own futures yes
that's not true okay
stacy
uh no you can absolutely make your own
that's that's the great thing is that
you can absolutely make your own
healthcare decisions not that these
people actually care about being able to
make your own health care decisions or
they just they just decided that they
cared about that again right now but for
the last two years of course they've
been they've been demanding that whether
you want to or not um here's a needle
injected into your body object this this
uh you know here's here's a substance
you need to object and inject into your
body
and then come back and do it again and
again and again you don't have a right
there so there's a healthcare decision
that uh that's that's not about you you
just have to do it because we're telling
you to do it
but the great thing is that this has
nothing to do with the healthcare
decisions by women because an abortion
is not a care decision
it's got nothing to do with health and
it's certainly got nothing to do with
care
abortion is the intense
the intentional direct destruction of
human life which is
that's not just not
health care that's the opposite of
health care
meanwhile aoc she made her way to the
out right outside the supreme court and
is now
looking to stage her own insurrection so
here she is we'll play this uh she's
outside with some protesters chanting
that this roe v wade decision is
illegitimate and she's calling for
people to go into the streets so let's
uh play that
[Music]
[Music]
oh
uh so the decision is illegitimate so
this is what you notice we've seen this
also on the left today that um
there there's people now calling for the
supreme court to be i think it was keith
olbermann yesterday i believe
uh or someone just as stupid as him
calling for the supreme court to be
abolished they want to get rid of it
entirely
and now she's saying that the decision
is illegitimate so she's calling into
question
this decision made by the supreme court
uh which
to me seems an awful lot like an
insurrection
she's calling it into question she is um
eroding
intentionally trying to erode the faith
that people have in our system
by saying that how is it illegitimate
i know you don't like the decision i
know you disagree with it
but in order for it to be illegitimate
there would have to be something
you know what have been illegitimate
what illegitimate is if the person who
leaked the decision had gotten their way
and their in their plan had worked
and through intimidation through violent
intimidation and harassment had
convinced some of the justices not to
sign on to this to this majority opinion
after all that would be illegitimate
but when you have justices who are
looking at the case
and making a decision based on what
seems right to them according to how
they interpret the constitution that's a
legitimate decision you might not like
it it's legitimate
um but on the left
something is illegitimate
if they don't like it
and institutions are broken
the moment the institution
fails to do the bidding of the left
that's what they mean
when they say that that something is
broken so the supreme court is broken
now because it failed to do exactly what
they wanted to do
and now she's calling for them to go
into the street knowing what that means
right i mean knowing that we've got
pro-abortion militant groups that have
openly very clearly been uh not just
threatening but promising
to commit violent acts against churches
and pregnancy centers
which by the way i mean how much of a
demon do you have to be to attack
pregnancy centers in the first place
churches and pregnancy centers
you might as well go after orphanages
next which maybe they will
a pregnancy center all they do is they
they help women who are
who need help who are pregnant and need
help
that's what they do that's that's their
sinister plot
and we've got pro-abortion militants
uh threatening to
and have already attempted to in many
cases burn these facilities to the
ground
and uh now aoc is saying go into the
streets so she knows that she's
encouraging that she's doing it quite
intentionally
all right
before we move on here i want to there
was a there's another great supreme
court decision yesterday this has just
been this has been a fantastic week this
has been a great this has been my
favorite pride month by far
it's just this is one that's going to
live forever in my in my heart
personally pride month of 2022.
so yesterday the supreme court
upheld the second amendment and thus
overturned a law in new york requiring
that law-abiding citizens get special
permission to conceal carry a firearm
and of course the left has already been
panicking over that now we're going to
add this into the mix and it's just
going to be a whole explosion but i want
to play
a couple of the reactions especially
from democrat leaders of the state so
we'll start with um kathy hokule
who says that you know this isn't this
is uh
the second amendment really just refers
to muskets and that's all it refers to
that's what she claims here listen
they were supposed to go back
to what was in place
since 1788 when the constitution united
states of america was ratified
and i would like to point out to the
supreme court justices that the only
weapons at the time were muskets
i'm prepared to go back to muskets
oh yeah the only weapons were muskets at
the time and so obviously
when our founding fathers said that the
right to keep and bear arms should not
be infringed they only meant
the arms the type of firearms that
existed in that moment in time
because they didn't know that technology
changes and that they weren't aware of
that and so they figured that
the type of firearms that existed
back then that that's all there would
ever be
and if only they had known that
technology would continue to improve in
advance then they would have said forget
this whole second amendment that's what
she's claiming
yeah you're right kathy that the
founders didn't have modern guns you
know what else they didn't have
abortion clinics
those didn't exist
they didn't have gay marriage
they didn't have transgenderism
so i mean none of those rights exist
either according to you
meanwhile eric adams for his part is
pledging to i'm not even sure exactly
what this means or if he knows what it
means but he's pledging to as mayor of
the city
undo the ruling listen
the opinion claims to be based on nation
historical past
but does not account for the reality of
today
it ignores the presence
and it endangers our future
while nothing changes today and we want
to be clear on that
nothing changes today
we have been preparing for this decision
and will continue to do everything
possible to work with our federal state
and local partners to protect our city
we will collaborate with other mayors
municipality leaders
and governors and will leave no unturned
stone
as we seek to undo and mitigate the
damage that we are witnessing today
undo and mitigate the damage but by that
he means the supreme court ruling so he
wants to undo and mitigate he's he's
openly saying that he's not going to
abide by this is the law he's not going
to abide by it and he's going to try to
undo it so another example of this this
is actual insurrection
being carried out by the mayor of new
york city uh one other thing on guns
this is a as usual a smart take from
jill falopovich who's a writer feminist
writer
and she and we're seeing a lot of this
kind of thing
she says the kind of people who
desperately want to carry concealed
weapons in public based on a generalized
interest in self-defense
are precisely the kind of paranoid
insecure violence fetishizing people who
should not be able to carry concealed
weapons in public in the first place
now the great thing about this claim
from her is that it could not be more
wrong once again it's the opposite of
the truth
concealed carry permit holders commit
almost none of the violent crime
a very very small percentage of the
violence
committed
in this country every day is is done at
the hands of concealed carry permit
holders
and it's so small that on the left when
they try to tabulate the statistics
to tell us um you know how much violence
gun violence is actually committed
by
people who have legal concealed carry
firearms um oftentimes they'll you know
they're going to throw things like
suicide into the mix there
which is tragic and terrible but that's
not exactly what you what what you
usually have in mind when you talk about
gun violence
um
but when you when you look at it more
honestly what you find is that again a
very very small percentage less than one
percent it's something like 0.7 percent
of gun violence is carried out by people
with with legal concealed carry firearms
and that doesn't even take into account
all the lives that they save
so this is just totally false
um the statistics show you that you are
the more people who are legally carrying
firearms
in your town where you live the safer
you are that's what the statistics
clearly shows all right we got to move
on um i'm just having so much fun with
all this this is a i don't know it's
just a great day here's one thing a
little bit on a little bit of a lighter
note so we go we go back to the biden
administration
first of all biden had a meeting with um
union and private sector leaders at the
white house yesterday maybe you've seen
this but
i have to mention it anyway he he
inadvertently flashed a card to the
camera
showing very specific instructions that
the staff had given him
and you can kind of see when you when
you zoom in you can see the instructions
are so they say
you enter the roosevelt room and say
hello to participants you take your seat
and i love how it's capitalized
you and yours so like take your your
seat not anybody else's don't take
somebody else's seat don't like take
another person's seat and throw it out
the window just take take your scene
press enters
uh you give brief comments
minutes
as opposed to hours
press departs you ask liz shuler afl-cio
president a question
note liz is joining virtually you thank
participants
you depart
apparently you should have also said you
don't show this card to the camera
uh maybe they should have added that
note in there too
here's the thing i have i have an
assistant and she makes uh itineraries
for me and they can be pretty specific
sometimes
but so i know a little bit about this
but they're not this specific okay
because an itinerary is like okay you go
to this place at this time
then then you go to this place and
you're giving a speech for x amount of
minutes or whatever but my itinerary
never says
you
put one foot in front of the other
propelling yourself across the floor in
a manner known as walking
you breathe in and out repeatedly so as
not to be rendered unconscious
these are the kind of instructions that
biden gets because you see not
i just wish here's what i here's the
tragedy as far as i can tell
i wish that um
they had given him one of these cheat
sheets when he was in rome
you know something that might have said
uh you
don't your pants in front of the pope i
think he really needed that on a sheet
of paper and it wasn't there so that's
really honest it's his aides fault for
not
keeping in mind not keeping that in mind
and not mentioning it
all right let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
well with roe v wade coming
to an end finally you may think that
this means the fight is also coming to
an end for for abortion against abortion
but abortion legislation returning to
the states means that the real battle is
only just beginning and there is no
group in america better position than 40
days for life to help fight this battle
40 days for life has 1 million
volunteers throughout the country
holding peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities you may be surprised to hear
that their largest presence is actually
in the country's bluest states with
california being their biggest state and
that's where they're going to be needed
the most now with roe v wade gone their
vigils have closed many abortion
facilities in america and nearly half of
those facilities were in liberal states
where abortion will continue to remain
legal after the fall of roe from san
francisco to chicago to seattle hardly
pro-life areas of course volunteers have
guided abortion workers to have a change
of heart and quit their jobs also so as
this issue gets out of dc finally uh 40
days for life is effectively changing
hearts and minds and the grassroots of
the pro-abortion movement check out
their locations podcasts and new book
what to say when the complete new guide
to discussing abortion at
40daysforlife.com
all right a little bit something
different for the comment section
instead of comments left by the sweet
baby gang we're going to do a little bit
of a roe v wade themed comment section
because i'm not quite done gloating
and celebrating as we all should be so
here are some some tweets not comments
none of these people left comments under
my youtube video as much as i would love
it if they did we're gonna go through
some tweets from uh prominent democrats
reacting to the roe v wade news we'll
just cycle through them i haven't seen
these yet but here's barack obama says
today the supreme court not only
reversed nearly 50 years of precedent it
relegated the most intensely personal
decision someone can make to the whims
of politicians and ideologues
attacking the essential freedoms
of millions of americans
and as always when they talk about the
essential freedoms of millions of
americans uh they are not talking they
are excluding all the americans in the
womb and you would think you want to
talk about essential freedom
the in the dictionary definition sense
of the term essential the most essential
freedom is the freedom to live but
barack obama has no problem with
throwing that out the window hillary
clinton is very upset she says most
americans believe the decision to have a
child is one of the most sacred
decisions there is and that such
decisions should remain between patients
and their doctors today's supreme court
opinion will live in infamy as a step
backwards for women's rights and human
rights no
actually the decision to have a child
is not really one that you have
with a doctor okay unless you're having
sex with your doctor and conceiving a
child with him
but
usually by the time you go to the doctor
it's you you already the child already
exists once again
the child is already there
so so the decision to have a child
that's already out the window okay that
window has closed by the time the child
exists
you're you already have the child
in a very literal sense like the woman
has the child in every sense of the term
has the child inside her in her body
which is a miraculous and beautiful
thing
unless you're on the left
nancy pelosi once again says today the
republican controlled supreme court has
achieved the gop's dark and extreme goal
of ripping away women's rights to make
their own reproductive health decisions
okay we've already heard from nancy
pelosi we got anybody else
chiming in
eric swalwell okay good we gotta we have
to include him here he says extreme
right-wing judges on the supreme court
just issued a death warrant
to women in america
they've decided that a piece of metal
designed to end life
is more valuable than the health and
safety of women in america
if this doesn't motivate you to vote
nothing a death warrant
how so
how do we get from roe v wade's
overturned uh which means that the
decision
about making abortion legal or illegal
falls to the states
so that's step one
step two
and then step three i'm not sure it's
left blank step four
women die
death warrant
uh and and by the way
if you read the decision and i read a
little bit of it to you but i would
really recommend that you go and read
and
it
you if you read it within with an honest
mind
there is nothing remotely extreme
happening in the decision
it is very logical it goes it explains
itself point by point
and once again the decision does not
mean that abortion is now illegal across
the entire country although
that has to be the next step
and that's the other thing for
pro-lifers is that um and i know i i
don't think i have to tell pro-lifers
this because they've been in this fight
for 50 years
but the fight's not over and in fact we
cannot be
we should celebrate this and be happy
for this great humanitarian victory this
great victory for human rights but we
should not be satisfied like celebrate
today pop the champagne but then
tomorrow it's back back to work
because although abortion now falls to
the states it's still going to be legal
in many of those states and the babies
who are still going to die in california
and oregon and vermont and you know
maryland and new york
those babies lives matter
so we're still fighting for them
and the ultimate goal yes is to make
abortion illegal across the entire
country a federal ban on abortion
a personhood amendment to the bill of
rights
that's the ultimate goal that's what
we're fighting for
well did you know that poor sleep can
cause weight gain mood issues poor
mental health and also lower
productivity and there's no there's a
few things more important to your health
than just getting a good night's sleep
and that you know there are some reports
that say sleeping less than six to seven
hours per night is linked to reduced
white blood cell count white blood cells
protect our body against illness and
disease fighting viruses bacteria and
more not many people realize this but
having a consistent nighttime routine
is incredibly important a better
tomorrow starts than tonight including
introducing beam dream beam is one of
the world's most innovative functional
wellness brands with unique products for
everything from sleep to focus and today
my listeners get a special discount
available for a beam's sleep product
dream powder it's their best selling hot
cocoa it contains premium ingredients
triple lab tested and you wake up
refreshed 98 of people surveyed fall
asleep faster when taking bean dream and
99 of people experience better sleep
quality just mix a beam dream into hot
water or milk stir and then you enjoy
before bedtime it's as simple as that
also beam just launched a brand new
delicious new summer flavor of dream
powder sea salt caramel sea salt camo
sea salt caramel dream powder tastes
just like the caramel drizzle on your
summer ice cream cone but with only 15
calories
better sleep has never tasted better or
been healthier and better for you don't
love it get your money back guaranteed
but i think you will love it for a
limited time get up to 35 off when you
uh go to
beamorganics.com walsh and use codewall
should check out that's
dot
beam
slash wall should use codewalsh for up
to 35 off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well this daily cancellation ends up
working out pretty well because given
the news of the day it's all about
babies and why babies are good and why
you should have them but it begins with
not with roe v wade but with a writer
for the atlantic as we know writers for
the atlantic are not the most perceptive
or insightful bunch as a rule and that
rule seems to hold true for atlantic
writer olga kazan who tweeted recently
quote
i'm still curious how women are supposed
to have kids before they're 35 if they
make 40 000 a year before they're 35 and
child care is 40 000
now the tweet has resonated enough to
earn nearly 80 000 likes with lots of
people in the comments chiming in to
agree that it's essentially impossible
for a woman to have kids under the age
of 35 unless she earns substantially
more than the average income for that
age bracket
and yet shockingly it turns out that um
you know many women have done exactly
this in fact through history literally
billions of women have
this is one of the curious features of
modern american life american life that
people are constantly proclaiming it
impossible to do the things which
billions of other people have already
done and are currently doing
so we can look around and see billions
of people doing something and then say
it's not possible okay that's impossible
no one can do it except for these 10
billion people
this is because most of the time
when we say that we cannot do something
the sentence is incomplete
we haven't really finished the thought
what we meant to say is that we cannot
do said thing
while still maintaining the comfort and
luxury that we've come to expect and
demand
we cannot do it easily we cannot do it
without effort
we cannot do it while um staying true to
our undying principle that we should
never have to make any personal
sacrifices of any kind
we cannot do it without getting off the
couch etc
one of these caveats or similar to it
usually silently accompanies our
declarations about what we cannot do and
that's certainly the case here
but olga is not alone far from it as
people put off having children more and
more putting it off so long that
eventually becomes a physical
impossibility in reality to have kids at
least without the help of a petri dish
in a science lab
the reason often given by by people who
put it off is that it's not financially
feasible to have kids
and this fear is encouraged by random
fake statistics pulled out of thin air
like the statistic that child care costs
40 grand a year
putting your kid in child care in
daycare says olga is as expensive
as a really expensive private school
now fortunately this is not remotely
true
in fact the most expensive the most
expensive state for daycare is
massachusetts on average and there it
costs an average of 20 000 a year to get
daycare which is absurdly high but it's
half of olga's estimate
but if you live in most other states
you're paying under 15. in many states
the average is under 10 000 a year in a
state like mississippi it's half that
now there are of course many other
fictional horror stories about the cost
of having children many of them coming
from alleged authority figures more
prominent than olga on twitter the usda
for example put out a report last year
claiming that the average child costs
fifteen thousand dollars a year
and this means that a family of three if
you do the math is forking over 45 grand
a year just to keep their kids alive
i'm supposedly spending 60 000 a year
just on my kids
that works out to um about 270 000 per
child to get them from age zero to age
18. then if you have four kids four or
five of them you know like i do then
you're you're in the hole for a million
plus
i mean you got to be a millionaire to
have kids
now admittedly with with biden's
inflation it's starting to actually feel
like you need to be a millionaire to
afford groceries and gasoline even just
for yourself but on average assuming
that hopefully the current trends don't
hold for the next 18 years
these figures are nonsense
it is certainly possible
possible
to spend 15 grand in a year on one child
i mean you could do that you could spend
triple that if you wanted to
yet there's no law of nature requiring
that kind of financial investment
if there was then billions of people who
have kids now and who've had them in the
past would not have been able to survive
and yet they did and they do
the consequence of this way of thinking
believing that you need to have massive
amounts of money in the bank just to
afford even one kid is that as mentioned
people put off starting families later
and later
you know we think that we should get
through young adulthood establish
ourselves build a life of some
some sort and then finally begin the
process of finding spouses and becoming
parents once we're safely ensconced in
the protective cocoon of middle age
that's what we think
speaking of finding a spouse notice how
olga never accounts for marriage at all
it would cost a woman 40 grand a year
for child care she says
but if you're doing it right the cost
which definitely will not be 40 grand
is shared by a woman and a man together
in the bond of marriage
we've been conditioned to see these
things on an individualized basis
we think that you know a man should make
a life for himself all alone and then
inject a wife and kids into this thing
that's already been constructed without
them
like set it all up and then introduce
the family
and this strategy leads to a lot of its
own problems
the man will often begin to resent his
family because they're intruding
this is not their life it's his
he can't look to his wife and kids and
say well they were here with with me
when i had nothing we were together from
the beginning we we climbed to this
point together rather he looks at them
and says i built this on my own i did
all this on by myself i climbed without
them this is mine
they don't know anything about it the
freeloaders
i think this is probably one of the
reasons why people who get married in
their 30s have higher divorce rates
because they've already established
their own things and get very possessive
of their own thing their own life that
they've made for themselves
walking the bumpiest parts of the road
together
struggling sacrificing suffering going
without
together this is what brings a family
together
that's why as i've always said
i think it's better to see marriage and
family as the cornerstone of adult life
rather than the capstone
in modern times we tend to favor the
capstone model we say that a young adult
should live through
young adulthood by himself save money
get all of his affairs in order and then
as the culmination as the at the
conclusion of this process as he enters
middle age then he should commence with
getting married and having kids
that way he'll be able to quote unquote
afford it
but the cornerstone approach on the
other hand says that it's better to
start your family at the beginning of
the process not at the end
build your adult life with your spouse
and children have them there at the
foundation of it all bring them in on
the ground floor so to speak
this is how nearly every culture in the
world has approached this issue until
ours
we flipped this well-worn battle-tested
model on its head and tried it the
reverse way and it really doesn't seem
to be working
the result has been higher divorce rates
lower marriage rates people are less
satisfied in life not as happy
population
populations are declining and to top it
all off the people who hold off on
having families for financial reasons
very often discover as mentioned that
they they they never reach a point where
they feel financially ready not at 25
not at 30 not at 35.
they sit around waiting for the dollars
and cents to add up while their
biological clocks tick away
until finally it'll cost them like 20
000 in an ivf clinic simply to conceive
a child when they could have done it for
free
and in a way that's a lot more fun by
the way
just a few years before that
this is supposed to be the financially
conscious approach which really doesn't
make a lot of sense when you think about
it
and that's why olga at the atlantic
is today cancelled but even more than
olga the atlantic
as you might have already heard row is
canceled day two
as the supreme court i think has issued
the greatest daily cancellation of all
time
and we thank god for that
enjoy your weekend enjoy the celebration
we'll leave it there for today talk to
you on monday stay safe
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin